so let's get into some of some of the
themes that as I said I have become the
central themes of what I'm trying to do
yeah yeah because you know I say to you
all the time as I said in the intro I'm
watching the news constantly and I like
I either text you sometimes or I'll call
you and be like god I wish your dad was
around because I because I can't do with
that right certainly and I don't know
anyone else they can that can skewer
stuff in that way so let's just hit a
couple of them so the religion one so
yeah already mentioned a little bit
about his history with religion was was
he an atheist did he describe himself in
any specific way no he did not use the
term atheist he felt atheism was as
dogmatic as any other ISM out there uh
you know lately I've been introduced to
what they call the humanist uh you know
kind of community which is something I
relate to a lot more I think he would
have felt better about that sounds like
they're not gonna have as many meetings
and armbands I things like that what she
used to talk about groups because he's
less kool aid I think yeah he felt any
great you know any group of people you
get groupthink and then where does the
individual thinking you know happen in
that situation so that always worried
him I think he's self you know named
himself mostly as an agnostic obviously
he didn't believe in the man in the sky
with the beard thing it's not like he
was thinking that was possibility but he
had a deep sense of oneness with the
universe he loved astronomy he loved
that idea of looking up and um you know
that that feeling you get when you look
I mean like Jesus were just a speck here
no and yet there's something about that
being a speck that expands us at the
same time so there was something around
that he was a man who dropped acid in
the 60s and had some transcendent
experiences about that and it or talked
to me about being high and having an
experience where he realized that he
really was at one with everything
including the old tennis shoe and the
gutter and that he realized that if he
was that everything was
him and he was everything and from that
moment on he said he felt safe because
he knew that no matter what he
encountered in life
he was only encountering a version of
himself
so that's that's pretty spiritual stuff
that's yeah I mean you can put it under
in that box spiritual and you could you
know you could talk about it from a
brain science way and say okay maybe
there's things in the brain that makes
us feel that way or whatever it is but
it is an experience that changes your
worldview and changes how you encounter
your life and other people yeah you know
and I think that did that for him yeah
do you think a lot of his sort of it
because when I think of it I think of
this sort of anti religion the rants
that he would go on yeah the church and
religion include how much of it was just
not even about religion specifically but
just about authoritarianism was about
control was that really what what it was
about it wasn't about religion well I
can't say I won't speak to him and I
don't really know at all what motivated
him to do those bits
I never was privy to that part of his
process he would sit me down during the
HBO taping and let me see it just the
way everyone else saw it I never knew
his process but sure I mean I think if
you looked at all of his material and
and sifted through it and analyzed it I
think authoritarianism would be a huge
aspect to it all that any one out I mean
he my dad never made it through a single
institution he encounter right got
kicked out of everything elementary
school junior high high school did not
finish high school
ninth grade dropout then join the
airforce early promoted and demoted I've
got a little piece of paper of his that
has all the listings of the promotion's
of the demotions that he had in the Air
Force oh yeah got kicked out of that and
then ultimately you know became this
straight suit clean-cut comic and even
that conservative form that he had to be
in in order to be a successful comic
because his dream was to be in the
movies eventually that felt you know too
restrictive and authoritarian for him
and he rebelled against that -
ultimately yeah he was always looking I
mean he talked about the line he always
you know a comics job is to find the
line
and across it and I think that's what
that's about is anyone telling you you
can't do something
alright let's cross it and really see
what we can do on the other side of that
yeah so let's just back up for a second
because you mentioned that at one time
your dad was this sort of it wasn't
conservative comic but he was he was
button-down yep kind of he was sort of
everyone else in this you say he was
that generic whatever that were but then
had a moment that it all changed do you
do you know what it was personally at
that moment or was it purely like was
LSD it was oh it was the drug I mean
here's the deal yeah on the inside he
was already the other person he had been
smoking weed since he was 14 his
politics were a little more conservative
growing up his mom was Republican you
know whatever they call him anything
anymore relative to Alec you know a
fiscal what every school conservative
Shana a social liberal right exactly um
and when he met Jack Byrnes his first
thing was he was a comedy duo with Jack
Byrnes Jack Byrnes was way left
progressive and my dad was more moderate
guy and Jack took him and pulled him and
taught him about everything and then of
course Lenny Bruce you know blew his
mind - yeah so on the inside dad was a
radical he was hanging out with
musicians in the village you know he was
he was one of them but he had to put on
this exterior in order to build this
career because in his mind he really did
he had this Danny Kaye plan and he
wanted to be like Danny Kaye in the
movies and he felt the way to do that
was TV and these nightclubs I mean
really there were no comedy clubs back
then yeah you were doing the Playboy
Club with a Copacabana and you were
opening for you know God knows four
seasons yeah I mean yeah he were lucky
was a 40 overtime per day yeah yeah I
mean he opened for The Supremes in Las
Vegas and 69 you know it's like you know
so but really think how crazy that is
like you can say it and we don't really
absorb what that means but your dad yeah
even before his transformation opening
yeah Supremes it seems so bizarre yeah
yeah and that was a that was a great gig
for him he was making a lot of money in
that gig yeah I think you tell a story
where he actually got fired from he got
I heard for that gig yeah yeah he was
making more money than he ever had made
and he said the word what was it is it a
sin that one or [ __ ] I think I said [ __ ]
that he got fired twice in Vegas yes sir
yeah yeah ass her [ __ ] and red foxes
down the street doing xxx stuff of
course so you know but but this was the
thing he realized he was entertaining
the parents of the people that he was
hanging out with right and and and
here's like another part of his outsider
status too was he was 30 in 1967 so he
was already too old for the hippies and
all the kids that were going through
that because they were all early 20s but
he wasn't relating to their parents
either sure so he was this interesting
bridge between those two generations but
related obviously much more to the
younger generation